good afternoon everyone thank you for
attending my talk the title of my talk
is the sin of high performance messing
messaging with Nats quick introduction
of myself my name is Valdemar Quevedo
you can find me in twitter wallach us
github is the same I'm a software
developer and observe I'm based in San
Francisco what I do the development of
the absurd and trusted platform which is
an uncontained
orchestration solution for a further
background in the past I was doing
developmental operations from a platform
service and a large e-commerce website
in Japan and that which was based on
Cloud Foundry and that was using nets as
part of its control plane it became very
large and deployment so that's how I
became more familiar with doing
operations on nets and I'm also a
maintainer of a couple of the client
libraries for Ruby Python 2 based on
tornado and I think I own for Python 3
and so about this talk things I want to
share with you is first of what is Nets
then what it's not the what is the
design behind that how it works and why
I like it then we want to start talking
on what is what what how can we start
using a nets for building distributed
systems so let's get it started and what
is nats nats is high performance messing
system it was created by Derrick
Collison originally in 2010 for cloud
foundry it was first written in Ruby
with the man-machine
then there was a rewrite in God in 2012
which gave it a lot of much many
performance benefits it is open source
under the MIT license license and you
can find it github under there that's -
I own organization and it's a very small
binary thanks to God the go team and
there's design decisions there it is
only 7 megabytes in size is one of the
smallest was a very small docker image
as well it's a single binary so it has
very few layers and has no other
deployment dependencies and so that's a
very convenient
in terms of the project and one of the
things one of the goals of it is that it
tries to act as an always available
dial tone for different clients to be
able to communicate within that within a
service with the service and but of
course one of its main characteristics
is this the performance which if you use
the Nats bench micro management tool
which is available in the repo here
we're sending one hundred million
messages and you can see that you can
get a throughput of around 10 million
messages per second with a single byte
which is still a byte micro benchmark
and which could be quite impressive but
for much of thorough benchmarks I highly
recommend the blogs are from Tyler
Strait which is in the audience and
there he makes a much better comparison
have nots fairs and worse all the
tracing balls because there are
trade-offs involved and in Nats compared
with these other missing systems so this
is the link and at the bottom so we
might need an update some of these
because Nats has been a lot mean as well
there and what this talk is not mainly
about only performance but how Nats keep
things simple so Nats has simplicity and
performance as its main traits so moving
on to the design behind Nats Nats has a
design that was kept constrained so that
is operationally simple and reliable as
possible but without compromising about
performance and scalability this is
because simplicity matters and you
familiar familiar with the world from
which he key there is a great talk and
the railsconf a couple of years ago
where I was fortunate that attend and
really really liked that I recommend
well explains that simplicity buys you
opportunity and then he goes on to
define then there is something called
tactile agility and by architectural
agility he means that having a system
that is that the gun the one you get by
having a system that is fundamentally
simple and that type of agility
dominates
any other type of agility and how not
achieve simplicity simplicity it does so
by having a consist a strictly limited
feature set it does nothing but pure
publish/subscribe so unlike other
massing existence for example it doesn't
have building persistence of messages
and that's what I don't have any exactly
ones delivery promises instead those
concerns are simplified away from that
as a thought exercise of to bring the
mind stuff what what is the problem and
that's trying to solve is think of
yourself what could be the fastest
simplest and most reliable way of
writing breathe into a socket to
communicate to one to one one to n
number of nodes for Nats this means
choosing tcp/ip and having an always
established TCP connection with the
server and over this obvious established
connection to the server you use a very
simple plaintext protocol and do nothing
but pure poly subscribe and it's a
fire-and-forget system with in terms of
delivery guarantees you could say at
most once delivered meaning that if
someone is not plugged into the system
and interesting to a subject then that
message will be just dropped into the
floor and this is the next protocol and
it's very simple it's very very few
number of commands you can publish
messages subscribing to a topic on
subscribe form it from the server you
would receiving a messages and there's a
ping and pong which both the client and
the server and I send each other an
initial info and we tell we tells the
client how to handle the connection with
the server and also the client can send
this connect payloads to label each
connection and there's a couple of error
notifications as well so I will just
make a quick run from today so the
protocol and this is a the demo
public site so you feel free to try it
as well and this is a very simple client
and tell name demo dotnet say you're on
the port 42 to
the first thing we get is this
infrastructure lens and also what is the
maximum payload size that we can use for
each one of the publish published
messages to the server and yeah we can
send an optional connect command it is
you have to send it in case the server
requires an authentication credentials
but here we just label on connection as
a that's a stranger client it has to be
a JSON string of course we can send a
ping and receive a pong back to server
which can be useful to measure the
round-trip latency and if both either
the client on the server
don't do this periodically and by
default this is an interval of every 2
minutes the server will chop the
connection off and take it out then take
the client out and this is the basic
subscribe functionality so here we
express interest on the hello subject
and we use an arbitrary identifier with
number 10 and this is this is all for
the local logic from the client and if
we send 5 bytes on this subject here you
can see like there's a number 5 and in
the control line DUSU met with this will
make the server expect the next pipe to
read the next 5 bytes and he doesn't
follow that then we'll consider that
it's not following the protocol and also
disconnected the client but if
everything goes well then we will
receive this in uppercase message on the
hello subject which is matching with the
original subscription we made and is
telling the client to read the next 5
bytes that the server is sending so here
we have sent our message to ourselves
it's only important to highlight here is
that the payload is opaque to the server
so for the server is just bytes and
meaning that it could be really anything
you can just on JSON message pack
protocol buffers that's up to the client
libraries to decide and so this is okay
for doing want to in broadcast
communication so let's talk about like
how the
Nancy chief doing one-to-one
communication with doing nothing but
pure publish/subscribe right so the
problem here is how can we send a
request and expect a single response
back with nothing but pure probably
subscribe the way nuts addresses this is
quite interesting and it does so by
having this ephemeral subscription
inboxes and their work the same as the
other types of subscriptions so it is
still pure Pali subscribe and the nuts
client libraries they have helpers to be
able create these and random strings and
all of the client libraries they're
quite sensitive to their reliability
because they're random involved there's
randomness involved they are sensitive
to the reliability of the available
pseudo random number generation that you
have in your runtime and but this is how
you can use it for example in the go API
this will give you unique inbox you can
use and then express to the server that
you're interested in this subject giving
an ID then we tell the server that we
have limited interest in this topic and
we only want to receive a single message
on this subscription that we have
locally identified with a number two
then we move on to actually publishing
the message and here we're telling a
mess sending a message on the health
subject tagging it with this F email
inbox and telling the server to read the
next five bytes that we have so please
then if and only if there is another
subscriber connected at that moment and
interested in helping into this subject
then it will be receiving a message
matching to that subscription that it
had done previously and it will perceive
the inbox that this other client has
sent and that will reduce this inbox to
make a reply on to that subject directly
and finally if the original requester is
still connected to the server and it is
has not received any other messages
because we're only interested in
receiving one
so the first one will win it will the
server will send the message on the to
this client so here's an 11 bytes
telling that I can help and this is
roughly the core functionality from Nats
and everything just builds on top of
this so I I guess I hope you can get an
idea that's a fairly simple protocol and
because a simple protocol you have has
very simple clients and all of the
client libraries and tend to have very
small footprint they don't have them
unlike this I'm not dancer so that's all
fly so complicated logic the nuts go
client it's all I have to double check
about it it's very small and we have
many of this original implementation was
the Rudi based client and reducing the
amount machine so but now the canonical
implementation is the go client so other
call the client libraries reference the
implementation please from this one to
see one what are the features that they
have to implement and but now there are
many more available officially the nuts
team is supporting like C C sharp Java
it's a couple of Python ones no GS and
elixir to there are many contributed by
the community too
there's even one from nginx this one is
quite interesting and is what we use at
them and up set up for dynamically
getting notification of where to reverse
through proxy the routes to the
applications are running inside of the
cluster so we don't do any kind of like
reloading of nginx configuration yet
another proxy that is going to be doing
that so it's just like by having a ninja
next hooked into them in Internet's it
will almost instantly know where to send
the traffic so yeah I think that's
pretty and something important to note
about the clients if that they're a
synchronous a mostly solid do you have a
synchronous operation and it was synchro
say yeah this is an example from the go
client where your interest
in the hello subject and we're sending
1000 messages but at this point in the
code there is no guarantee of having
actually sent these bytes so we not have
to do an extra step if we're interested
in having ensuring that we have actually
sent this reason for this is that there
is an internal engine being to the
clients where they do quality of the
variety in order to again not just be
right into the sockets all the time so
in order to ensure that we have actually
sent all of these messages we append an
extra ping at the end of the buffer and
we make a future so that we're expecting
a punk back from the server and this way
we can ensure that the server has
consumed all of the Bands our win
sending and in the order that we write
into the socket conscientia this is one
of the worst ways of ensuring that
measuring Nets performance like
something's like there are new users
from Nets and they hear that happen it
has it has good performance and it's
really fast so they make this simple
loop we're just sending as many messages
as possible and they have this other
subscription and they try to measure her
like how long did it start to finish
consuming all of these messages it's
quite quite funny what happens when you
try to do this so here we have in the
top screen the client sending as many
messages as possible in the middle is
the server and you can see that there's
low consumer detected errors been locked
into the server and at the bottom
there's a small utility that like
routing go it's not stopped which when
it turns gives you this terminal UI to
monitor the server and you can see
there's a slow consumer count increasing
and so basically the original client is
becoming disconnected and then trying to
reconnect and disconnected trying to
reconnect trying to sense and all of
those messages but the server is just
connecting it reason for this is that
the client is becoming a slow consumer
since its said that it was interesting
to into this hell
subject hello subject but because it is
so busy and sending all of these
messages this the server has to
continuously increase the pending data
size from the client so at the point
this could affect the whole service so
it becomes unsustainable for it and it
will just disconnect it and basically
the not server is protecting itself this
is because Nats is not only performance
and simplicity and it's also resilient a
messaging server which is called three
main traits that define deployment ation
of nets this not all the features that
it has
there's also subject routing support
will broadcast you can do authorization
rules on them and there's distribution
cue distribution cue groups and
clustering mode as I said at them you
can upgrade to a TLS connection and has
monitoring endpoints like bar C style
from what you can get the state from
there from the server is an example of
how the wild cards work here we have a
dot separate dot separated and subject
where we can if we can use them if you
the asterisk wildcard then it will match
to anything that is published on this on
this subject much into this welker one
example from this is since we know that
all of the Nats requests are going to be
underscore uppercase inbox we can
subscribe to all of the requests that
are happening in through the server by
using underscore inbox dot asterisk and
there's even a stronger wildcard which
is called the full wildcard this one
will match everything after the dot two
that is published on on the server so if
we make us hello dot full wildcard
subscription this will match messages
such as hello world dot again so on it
contains continues to match this is very
strong so if you try to connect right
now to the demo dot that's how you
end point and subscribed just on the
full wild card you will start seeing all
of the messages that are happening right
now in the server so yeah I think
someone is publishing some JSON messages
all the time and if you try to publish
on the underscore since you can see that
the server this allows you because it is
reserving that name for internal
messages and you can customize this by
having a static configuration from the
server where for example you can have an
abuser only being allowed to make
requests and Alice user being able to
subscribe and publish to anything this
is Roebling sunday well-muscled feature
set from nets so next I want to start
covering on the what are some of the
examples from actually using nets and
building this with systems with it so
this is a familiar scenario for many I
think so
we may have an external API server with
its being bad at receiving requests by
an external load balancer and this one
by each in standard is receiving a
request we'll have to talk with this
other internal services like from
service e which then has to talk to this
other service beam for internal
communication if we horizontally
horizontally scale this deployment then
it might look something like this where
everything is point-to-point connecting
to each other and it becomes this the
whole dead star micro-services kind of
thing and they will have to start
thinking about how to do communication
within this system and we may think
where should we use just just use HTTP
everywhere or some points on forum
point-to-point RPC and we have to solve
the problems of like how to do service
discovery and load balancing of the
services and
if at this point we are interested in
having in concern having an
sub-millisecond latency performance yeah
it can get interesting but this is
because is the nature of a distributed
systems right which is tend to be is
episode fun so what does net gives us
Nance gives us a basic published
subscribe based low latency mechanism
for communicating one to one one to n
number of nodes and we have these always
established connection to the server
Nach is not a system where you have to
create a new connection for each one of
the requests that you want to send it is
meant to have always this connection and
basically have an a lay a dial tone so
it is supposed to be an easy to use
because it lies near the literal
implement definition easy and so
communicating through Nats may look
something like this where we have all of
the services there plot internets then
you may think but then this makes Nats
become a single point of failure and I
don't really want to have single point
of failures in my discipline system
there's a way to prevent this by making
a full mesh cluster mode from Nats so
this way you can have at your different
services connected into into one of them
nuts nodes and they don't necessarily
have to be the same no if you see the
arrows here we have these services
connected to this node and these are
connected to this one and then full mesh
one hub clustering mode from Nats
will be routing the messages through all
of the subscribers publishers and
because of the thanks to the build team
client reconnection logic whenever
one of these nose nose goes away or dies
on crashes well yeah the client
libraries will reconnect and to another
available immediately available server
and the API for doing this is just use a
comma separated list of the of the
server's they're available whether it's
a bonus now the client says of recent
releases they have they can discover the
topology from the cluster dynamically
this is an example of the auto discovery
so let's say that you have your
infrastructure in AWS or some
cloud-based deployment and you create a
box and we have your running nets and
you don't really know what are the other
IP is from this the other cluster nodes
but you create one and then telling
these new Nets server where the other
server is so this will create the mess
the mesh and as soon as you do this yeah
the original server will notify all of
the clients where is there then where is
the new member from the cluster and all
of these clients will reconfigure
automatically and be aware of where this
other nuts server is and if you add yet
another node the same thing will happen
and now the clients are aware of the
full made cluster topology meaning that
if this server dies for some reason and
well they are here they're all connected
now it's all good but if the one goes
away by default they will randomly try
to reconnect to one of one of the other
immediately available and nodes within
the cluster so on talk about some
examples of how to actually use this and
that's for communicating very very basic
example could be for example doing
heartbeat and these are very basic
mechanism for example to publish and you
can you can have your services
periodically published heartbeats on on
a subject so that you can express the
lightness of the of the service and you
can leverage this harvest to create this
some sort of discovery as well so here
you use the wild card on the on the
service dot asterisk don't heartbeats
and you will receive all of the other
publishes from the note and so you can
discover these who else is talking in
inside of the cluster and as nuts also
supports distribution cues and the way
to use distribution cues is when you
well the use cases where you don't
necessarily want to broadcast all of
your messages and rather you want to
distribute the work between a set of
workers and the way to do this to use
this functionality is by having a making
a subscription and just like the other
subscriptions let's say service dot a
separated by the space and workers this
will create a distribution Q named
workers so now if we send a published
message on this service dot a each one
of these messages will be balanced
randomly among the service this
different service notes so it's not
broadcasted anymore each one of them
will receive it randomly yeah it's not
round-robin randomly and the API for
doing this is a queue subscribe and here
we are subscribed to the service a and
using the name username workers for this
group something important note of Nats
the way the addition cues work is that
Nath's does not assume the audience
meaning that you can have multiple
distribution cues from the same same
subjects or here we have
we sob we're subscribing to service a
using distribution q named workers we
could have in this in parallel and so on
service dot a helpers this machine group
and even a wild card which will be
matching on anything that is a series of
ABC if we publish a message they all
will be receiving the message right so
Nazis does not well this is what we call
by not assuming the audience and this is
where not really shines and if we were
interested in having the lowest latency
response from one of the service nodes
by the very definition by the way but I
did it by the very definition of the
Nats request the first message that you
get back from a request in net is the
one with the lowest latency and so this
is because then that's requests were
designed for this basically and their
API for this is the let's use the
connection and send a request in service
V for example telling them with the
payload and in the API from the clients
you need to give a timeout client
timeout after which you will give up
waiting for this message and but if
there is other subscriber on this
service being willing to help then this
other subscriber can use this inbox to
reply back and request help back and
something important note here is that an
instant messaging system and also you
need to be more careful with the error
handling or example the reason why
something failed could be many things so
in in from the client side you're on may
you're only making a request and
expecting a single response and let's
say that you hear the timeout
these could have a cure for a number of
reasons it can have been the case that
the service was unavailable at that time
and there was no one really connected
into the system or maybe it didn't
receive the request but just the service
the service took too long to reply back
or maybe it was processing the request
but it crashed while I'm handling this
so we need to be more careful when how
to do error handling in these cases and
for example if we want to confirm that
services is available we could have a
and all of these services have its own
inbox and they might make an extra
request on to get basically to check if
there is anybody out there willing to
help and then this other service could
reply back with his own inbox and then
we use that another that inbox to
communiqués to request and communicate
directly to this order to this service
note and so okay so just to summarize
and that's a simple fast and reliable
solution for the internal communication
of a distributed system especially if
you're flexible when in the cut when how
to handle the internal communication in
it and it does choose simplicity and
reliability reliability over guaranteed
delivery but this does not mean that
NASA will constrain the guarantees from
your service right if you were at the
papers will of gum that happened a
couple of days ago on there was this
great talk on the end-to-end which
covered the end-to-end argument and
there it was saying that
this type of guarantee is for your
application you need a separate line on
lower subsystems and instead like put on
a coat demand higher layer because and
you can if you don't do so by having
these other intimacy optimization in
lower layers you can end up wasting your
time and causing confusion since there's
no guarantee that it will give these
guarantees on the higher layer and there
isn't even a stronger variation that
argument which even causes a it is
harmful to to do so so no still quoting
a kind Anna Taylor treat who gave a
great talk about nets and he put it very
succinctly I thought we can always build
stronger grantees on top but we can
always remove them from below and
meaning that if we start thinking in
terms of for example having designer
system to be able to replay the messages
instead and then that becomes more
important than having just guaranteed
delivery and if we can design our system
so that you can safely retry the request
that can be better than having exactly
ones delivery and also if we're our
system is can sustain having rearranging
of the messages and this can be better
than just having order delivery and our
system could end up being more resilient
by following this trait and but again
this is not net and this there's a
related nuts project which is trying to
address these concerns and it's named
not streaming and if you want to check
it out
so I'm okay on time but so I wish that's
it for my talk so I really thank you for
attending and feel free to play with a
demo site and I think there's time for
Q&A too
reckon demo that's
so yeah you have to there some routing
happening between the servers so if the
server is aware of there's a subscriber
interesting to the subject then you will
be routing the message to the son or
they're not yeah that's basically let's
say yeah it's a very sensible example of
using it
yeah any other questions yes how often
so yeah that really depends on day yeah
on the application so so so how often
does the server loses messages and it
used sudden that's really not
responsibility from Nance from the way
it was design right so not will try to
send the message but if there is no one
really connected to consume that message
to receive it then that was it for that
message I mean it used got not be sent
yeah not be received for by anyone yeah
no yes
so yeah I mean Nazis do son quarantined
number of production systems I mean you
can see that website to look at the full
list of who's putting in production I
think like many other deployments on
cloud foundry for example they use nets
and they have deployment level
applications as well so so yeah we have
some quite usage for the type of
problems that Nazi solving yeah
yeah I mean that sounds like a st. use
case like for internal communications
odd components using as a control plane
yeah and that's is very suited for that
yes yeah okay yeah
none i'm not streaming it's a basically
the mount on top of nats and so you
would use a snap itself it's not
supplication you could say and on top of
that it creates this other layer where
it tries to give you this type of
guarantees where exactly once delivery
and replaying the previous messages that
have been sent and no one consuming for
example so so yeah i try to address all
the concerns that are in this is light
and but i guess the point here is that
those concerns were separated with two
different projects and
yes
in the other question
so for that yeah locally we have cattle
trading audience and he did a great job
at showing that and so what what is it
ten per sentence
yeah but I mean we can talk later on
this one yet
and
okay
if not then yeah if there's any a
question then I would like to thank
again for your time and hope you like
enjoying nights and play with the demo
server and I'll I'm around to talk if
you want to check out the demo or yeah I
can help you okay thank you